effectivement tu as mon commence par
parler de ce projet de loi en examen
cette semaine au Sénat pour accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et Madame Lamy s'il y a un point de
blocage avec la droite sénatoriale il
concerne le fameux droit de veto des
mers à l'implantation par exemple du
néolienne sur leur commune est-ce que
sur cette mesure il peut y avoir au
final un compromis avec le gouvernement
et si oui lequel alors je crois que tout
le monde travaille sur ce projet texte
qui sort de la commission d'abord je
veux dire que beaucoup de maires ne sont
pas à l'aise nécessairement avec la
rédaction actuelle du projet et pour des
raisons bien légitimes puisque ce pro
tel qu'il est rédigé aujourd'hui le
projet loi prévoit que des mères qui
sont mitoyens de la commune qui
accueillerait le projet d'éoliennes
terrestre ou de méthanier puisse donner
leur avis et faire un veto sur le projet
d'un maire donc ça je pense que c'est
compliqué c'est d'autant plus compliqué
que ça se fait au tout début du projet
c'est-à-dire à un moment finalement on a
très peu d'éléments sur l'impact
environnemental sur économique sur
l'impact énergétique du projet et donc
cela peut donner lieu à beaucoup de
contentieux et je n'osent imaginer des
contentieux entre deux mers je crois que
ce ne serait pas très positif et un
certain nombre d'associations l'ont bien
compris je lisais ce matin le communiqué
de presse d'intercommunalité de France
qui appelaient à revoir cette rédaction
et aller plutôt sur une planification
écologique partant des territoires et
c'est très exactement dans cette
direction que nous nous souhaitons aller
c'est-à-dire permettre aux élus du
territoire de définir des zones qui sont
propices à l'installation des énergies
renouvelables et faire en sorte que ces
zones bénéficient d'un coup de pouce
dans les appels à projets par exemple
d'énergie renouvelable de la part du
gouvernement ce que veulent en fait les
mères c'est de ne pas voir apparaître
des projets dont ils n'ont jamais
entendu parler et qui ne correspondent
pas à leur vision leur territoire mais
en revanche d'être accompagner dans la
planification en matière d'énergie
renouvelable tout le monde a bien
compris qu'on a besoin de produire de
l'électricité en France que c'est un
point essentiel pour notre indépendance
énergétique pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français pour la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et évidemment pour la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique nous
sommes aujourd'hui trop dépendant des
énergies fossiles qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cet amendement sénatorial qui
est prévoit de repousser au-delà d'une
distance de 40 km des côtes les
éoliennes offshore le gouvernement
pourrait dire oui à cette mesure alors
là c'est un problème et ce n'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est notamment j'avais au
téléphone le maire de Dunkerque encore
ce week-end j'ai parlé avec le maire du
Havre j'ai parlé aussi avec beaucoup de
groupes politiques le risque derrière
cette mesure qui sur le papier peut
paraître simple et de bon sens c'est
qu'en réalité on met à l'arrêt toute la
filière éolienne marine d'abord parce
qu'il y a 40 km des côtes dans la Manche
et dans la mer du Nord et bien vous
n'allez pas pouvoir construire du tout
d'éoliennes flottante c'est la même
chose en car il y a des canyones à cet
endroit là et donc on ne peut pas
accrocher une installation à cette
profondeur et puis donc cela
concentrerait les éoliennes marines sur
la façade atlantique en particulier en
dans les Pays de Loire et en Bretagne je
ne suis pas sûr que les élus le
souhaitent et puis pour aller plus loin
d'un point de vue technologique
aujourd'hui la seule technique maîtrisée
qui permet d'avoir des installations de
2 gigawatts qui correspondent grosso
modo à la production d'une centrale
d'une réacteur nucléaire et bien ce sont
des installations posées et
malheureusement la géographie de la
France est faite de telle manière que
c'est pas si loin c'est pas à 40 km des
côtes qu'on peut le faire mais je pense
que là aussi il y a un chemin et je sais
que beaucoup de groupes ont à cœur de
faciliter le développement des énergies
renouvelables à condition que ce soit
accompagnée et avec les élus et pas
contre les élus des territoires
[Musique]